[Musique]
m
de morello
[Musique]
salut éternel
sur le plateau de l'émission ils se
foutent actu
on s'appelle nokia
andreu aimable au caire
l'autre
van den bon soir alors quand je pense
que vous présenter le journal du hard
qu'on écoles aga khan al ain et qu'on ne
voit jamais
j'arpente peu les couloirs de canal bon
en tout cas changer dans les garages
voit la chanteuse donc avec un premier
album qui s'appelle déclaration dont un
single est déjà à quatrième au top
singles
c'est vrai qu'avec vos parents était
contre le fait que vous chantiez qu'ils
auraient préféré que vous gardez votre
boulot tranquille dans le porno
n'ont rien n'est sûr alors vous êtes dit
à une époque où les chanteuses
ressembler actrice porno pourquoi je
ferais pas directement chanteuse
finalement mais c'est réussi en tous les
cas
andré manoukian bonsoir julien
julliard gagner c'est formidable à la
finale de nouvelle star c'est énorme
ouais donc penser que déjà l'année
dernière c'était top et tout le monde
disait vous n'allez jamais pouvoir venu
avec le phénomène la tortue christophe
et là on a trouvé encore un autre
janvier via l'île de la tortue donc ce
serait comme al iman lui 1
andré manoukian vous avez un prénom de
chaussures un nom de sacs à main et un
verre mais mia
ça fait plaisir
obama entend bonsoir bonsoir alors
castagnettes pourquoi n'y ait pas
dire le coeur ne pas sélectionner des
garçons il est moins bon que les autres
oui s'il n'est pas sélectionné ce soir
estime itx mire un chien je suis pas
d'accord en plus moi
je dis castanet
fait j'y comprends rien du tout mais
j'espère en tous les cas que ma tenue
toute noire all blacks va pas vous
rappeler de trop mauvais souvenir quand
même non non non non non c'est vrai que
le rugby c'est un jeu qui jouait à 15
contre 15 et à la fin c'est les
all-blacks qui gagne c'est ça la règle
pas toujours pas toujours vrai mais les
test-matches épisode et crash test avec
le nom oui mais là je me servais que le
respect que j'ai il y avait seize
nouveaux joueurs dont il y avait
99 % de l'équipe qui a fait le coup de
gong qui était pas là bas mais bon vous
dire qu'ils sont les meilleurs au monde
d'aujourd'hui c'est une vraie vérité
aussi bas c'est à dire qu'à partir de
mots il n'y a pas un joueur de l'équipe
qui sort sur un fauteuil roulant vous
estimez que vous avez gagné
berne a voulu par leur être votre
biographie chez michel lafon qui
s'appelle le rugby m'a fait homme dont
les droits sont reversés à l'association
greffe de vie et je vous en félicite
voilà
alors omar et fred
et on peut dire que vous êtes les les
bataille et fontaine de l'humour
mais c'est pas encore fait virer par
votre actualité bien sûr c'est le dvd du
sav des émissions votre spectacle qui
est en tournée on parlera du premier
album de mokobé mais bon la vraie actu
quand même c'est le mariage doma
énorme alors comment ça se prépare
bessaih et c'était dans les tuyaux
nathan d'un jour j à l'acheter un
barbecue
s
[Musique]
alors on continue avec les images de la
semaine et on peut jouer avec l'image la
plus miraculeuse de la semaine
évidemment c'est l'accident de kubica au
grand prix du canada et puis sa
résurrection
je sais à présent une bonne
santé je donnais du tout alors l'hommage
la plus tard fournes la semaine
maintenant c'est un clip de l'onu pour
les réfugiés c'est magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fin
oh
c'est beau
le travail des
jeunes du film délivrance avec le banjo
ouais ça recommence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
starr en gros comme ça
sa longe cavale réussie
[Applaudissements]
m
andré manoukian
ils font la même chose avec gilles
servat
soyez faire ça aussi il nous a bon j'ai
essayé déjà beaucoup avancé
[Musique]
alors l'image la plus vie conjugale la
semaine c'était les violences de quoi
sont capables et m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
eh bien on va bientôt se marier mais
donc
voilà c'est pas compliqué or jean luc
delarue donc on a retrouvé des images de
jean luc delarue quand il était tout
petit avec son papa et déjà il
supportait pas lexomil vous allez voir
jean luc delarue de la semaine
ça donne envie vers les enfants je vois
pas non plus sur nous et les femmes de
notre époque où les enfants à 30 ans
maintenant ballons géants prendre un
carton voici maintenant l'image la plus
jacques martin de la semaine ce terrible
ça se passe dans une maison de retraite
c'est pour eux
[Musique]
gürsel a
maintenant l'image la plus qu'un mirage
la semaine les vieux aussi un plan pour
le débarrasser de la racaille
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors si vous aussi
vous avez comme ça des pépites du net
vous les envoyer en les diffusant rigole
c'est sympa breizh l'image la plus con
de la semaine par la plus guy lux de la
semaine c'est un jeu idiot vous allez
voir ça va bientôt arriver en france je
suis sûr
[Musique]
tu vois cette idée
ces numéros japon
comprendre la forme
centres de tris tu vois
[Musique]
sans limite et j'ai pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bientôt sur vos écrans et maintenant
l'image la plus stade français la
semaine spéciale dédicace à part à la
porte qui va ramasser la savonnette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il veut faire une pâte français
à l'égard de la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
politique
m 1
[Musique]
je le verrais l'émission qui se joue des
tours
ouais
ah bon ça
alors bernard laporte dans votre livre
vous racontez les valeurs qui ont porté
votre vie et qui vous ont permis de
réaliser le rêve de votre vie une
publicité pour du jambon
nous allons donc maintenant décerner la
vienne d'or du meilleur people pour
vendre du jambon
c'est pas omar
alors liane foly
véronique genest
clémentine célarié
lio ou bernard laporte moi je trouve que
celle qui a l'air république au 06 et
véronique genest je sais pas de quoi tu
te rappelles là bas j'étais tout jeune
de gilles vigneault les là dessus comme
un fou excusez moi mais c'est vrai
j'ai bien dit m ou
alors vianne car voilà celle dont je me
souvenais ce que véronique genest ouais
tu m'a marqué comme ça je me suis dit
est ce que leur futur non non non mais
elle m'a remarqué en tant que vendeuse
de jambes les enfants moi celio lio moi
aussi celio c'est la seule qui m'a
presque donne envie d'en manger
là länder du meilleur plus folles pour
vendre du jambon est attribué à
véronique genest et lyon
[Musique]
désolé la
laissez pas vous après d'autres trucs en
même temps bon pied a alors publié chez
michel lafon votre bios intitulé le
rugby m'a fait homme vous y raconter
comment vous avez découvert le rugby à
l'âge de 9 ans voyez tout à fait dans
une ville de 2000 habitants où le rugby
est roi pourra compter aussi comment
cette passion vous a permis de vous
reconstruire après un grave accident de
voiture à l'âge de 21 ans c'est en fait
vous roulez vous vous endormez platanes
à 120 alors ques et le jour où ma
libération de l'armée ouais et on m'a
dit mais le rugby ce sera certainement
fini j'ai fait moins de 1 semaine de
commun et donc effectivement je me
voyais pas vivre ça le rugby qui était
vraiment ma passion et puis bon le
bonheur a fait que
huit mois après les chirurgies qui
m'avait dit il ya devant des choses que
vous ne jouiez plus est venu me voir et
m'a dit maintenant je vous autorise à
rejouer des scènes très belle c'est
quand vous faites amenés en voiture au
bord du stade et que vous êtes là vous
pouvez pas jouer mais vous regarder les
autres jouer vous regardez les coûts et
tout c'est assez wen a cette chance
ouais alors vous racontez votre premier
pas de joueurs de capitaine d'entraîneur
et laventure du stade français avec max
guazini continue toujours d'ailleurs
vous avez vu la semaine dernière comme
ton mais 80000 personnes au stade de
france pour le match de championnat
pas de duel final pour match de poule on
arrive de nouvelle zélande à wellington
pour un match international il y avait
que trente quatre mille personnes de
quoi donc sa montre il était le blake
donc ça montre bien que ce qu'il a fait
était nombre max
alors voilà vous raconter comment vous
êtes devenu sélectionneur du quinze de
france et puis aussi comment après la
coupe du monde de la rentrée vous avez
sans doute vous lancer dans la politique
bernard c'est une des possibilités vous
étiez quand même au fouquet's avec
sarkozy le sort de son élection quand
même oui bien que la grand monde là bas
douste-blazy clan pas les gérants
je sais pas mais je crois que c'est un
privilège de bien connaître nicolas
parce que je le dis haut et fort c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup taisez
vous taisez vous c'est des élections
papa droit d'en parler pendant voilà non
mais c'est horrible je vous n'êtes pas
un faux pas parler ils sont partis quand
même la vague bleue ça existe alors moi
vous savez dernière je connais pas grand
chose au rugby pour moi c'est un peu un
jeu où les mecs ont des ondées maillot
rose y pose à poil dans les calendriers
ils mettent leur tête entre les jambes
de leurs partenaires c'est spécial ordis
caresse les couilles dans la mêlée non
c'est vrai démon personnes ramasse le
savant sous la douche on l'a vu ça va
quand même pas faire un petit coup ils
ont offert un petit quizz rugby ou queen
c'est le prix de la baguette paris on
peut y voir max guazini et 2 les deux
parisiens
c'est quand même plutôt un truc de mecs
des deux pics
on y voit parfois des films elles
peuvent se faire chier les deux villes
que
c'est la même chose au rugby et queen
vous allez voir des tenues super
moulante
trente mecs qui se rentrent dedans et 2
souvent après tu peux [ __ ] soir les
deux
c'est la même chose que je peux dire que
c'est un truc de tablettes le réguler
quand même à la fin tout le monde se
félicite
à la fin tout le monde aime bien montrer
sa [ __ ]
même si l'industrie qui est posé à poil
dans les magazines à la c'est le rugby
[Applaudissements]
le sujet de la semaine en société c'est
une étude qui vient de sortir sur la
sexualité des seniors les gens baissent
de plus en plus vieux de 7 à 77 ans
comme tintin et les études le confirment
on peut faire l'amour après 80 ans
évidemment le problème apprécié de
trouver quelqu'un
alors puisque les sessad interdit de
parler politique de quoi pourrait en
parler et ben de sexe évidemment avant
par les deux sexes pour faire son malin
maintenant c'est plus pour faire comme
tout le monde du sexe à la télé dans la
pub les magazines tout le monde est
obsédé
on sait que les hommes ne pensent qu'au
sexe toute l'année c'est pour ça qu'ils
adorent les calendriers ou les flics
sont à poil de janvier à décembre chez
les femmes c'est pas nul toute l'année
ils suivent les conseils des magazines
pour justement ressembler à s'écria
toile qui pèse quant aux garçons hélas
comme c'est l'été on y va du supplément
sexe le sexe n'est plus taboue subversif
c'est quasiment devenu obligatoire comme
la sécurité sociale des cinq ans les
mômes sont censés tout savoir sur le
bidule de papa ou lisant la chose à
maman à 10 ans ton premier porno à 12
ans ton premier rapport et après on
n'arrête plus de baiser jusqu'à la mort
parce que c'est ça le nouveau truc même
les vieux aujourd'hui doivent maintenir
leurs performances sexuelles regarder la
pression permet tait magazine notre
temps 4 millions de lecteurs et en une
avant l'été un concours de mannequins
pourront kim est d'exciter les hommes à
60 ans marie-france soi-disant à jonas
de mémère sort son dossier sexe de 30 à
60 ans tu m'étonnes avec la ménopause
puis besoins sont réceptifs celle retour
de l'insouciance et avec le viagra tout
est possible avant on voulait être
heureux maintenant on veut jouir c'est
vrai que le bonheur c'est un peu fades
comparés à l'orgasme un orgasme
permanent de 7 à 77 ans voilà ce que
nous voulons oui oui oui hollywood
[Applaudissements]
peut-être que bientôt on va aller mais
en cause de retraite
j'imagine et vos parents quand carrément
non non non tu vas déjà un chat anono
c'est un truc c'est vrai que les gosses
à 10 ans et regardent leur premier porno
et tout ça ouais est ce que c'est vrai
qu'au aussi enfin je sais c'est pas
parce que que les jeunes filles
maintenant ils font l'amour d'une
manière différente que autrefois parce
que comme il regarde tous des films
pornos et les mots mais ils font des
trucs insensés de suite quoi ben moi je
serais moi personnellement en ce qui me
concerne j'ai pas regardé de films
pornos jeune j'ai fait l'amour la
première fois à 16 ans comment tu savais
j'étais avec mon copain qui avait quatre
ans de plus que moi et qui avait déjà
pratiqué dans greg ouais j'avais tout va
et toi à quel âge 16 ans par la wii avec
rag aussi
on est partis au cap d'agde on est
partis au cap d'agde tous les deux avec
ride voilà c'était la grève
des millionnaires
non mais c'est assez encourageant parce
que finalement on se dit que quand on
aura la paix
[Musique]
clara morgane
vous sortez votre premier album qui
s'appelle des clara si on voit là moi il
m'a fallu lire trois fois pour combien
déclare est le premier single sexy girl
est entrée directement quatrième au top
singles en vous félicitant
vite être écrit par des textes
autobiographiques
alors dans j'aime le duo que vous faites
avec lord kossity vous dit l'explication
de texte je suis libre comme l'air à
cette marche avant ou arrière
mais ça c'est un truc j'ai réfléchi je
ne comprends pas début surtout
le texte juste joué sur ça c'est vrai
que j'ai employé des mots qu'on avait
peut-être envie dans le temps tu me
touche du doigt cherché - mieux que ça
je veux que tu n'examine ne donne pas ta
langue au chat s'appelle un peu à la
sensualité mais ça vienne deuxième
lecture qui qui qui veut dire aussi bon
et c'est de pas toujours voir la
première phase et on a tous différentes
facettes et voilà lol à l'arrêt
dénonçant le regard des passants
ouais
[Musique]
jamais
je n'écoute pas
[Musique]
chan
le choix
chocat
toi
5 6 2
[Applaudissements]
ou alors qui est sexy qui n'est pas sexy
ça dépend pour qui on va faire un quiz
sexy or not ségolène royal sexe sexy
elle est devenue pas mal je pense qu'il
a pris la côte est comme ça erratique et
tout envie de
ségolène
cécilia sarkozy bernard oui très sexy
mais pas trop quand même les gaffes mais
c'est un total de
rachida dati bonjour
aïe aïe aïe elle a un côté de nice fabre
un peu
un très joli
le magazine
mélissa theuriau alors là ah oui oui on
la jette pas énorme mais on reste
pantois
elle a été élue première femme dort ans
la puce est seul ami top sexy non je ne
trouve pas ma si ça mais surtout en les
yeux c'est un festival de couleurs c'est
incroyable c'est que tu pars en voyage
elle arlette chabot
bah oui alors là je vois qu'arlette
chabot et de nîmes soit cette année il
fera pas la peine de me poser la
question le chien
est rechargeable à trouver sexy d'un
maraudeur chazal ouais t'as aussi
bien chez elle quand elle présente le
journal ou dans voici
c'est tous les étés sur la plage a les
seins à l'air c'est officiel est encore
plus folle et je trouverais ça lui va
bien les salaires moncler cet été tu
nous as la même chose que d'habitude
françois fillon avoir bobo
diane's
pourquoi vous grimaces et non mais
pourquoi passe pas on réfléchit
benjamin castaldi
trop fraîche pour faire sa femme depuis
son plus jeune âge par ait tiré par les
terrains
mais c'est bien comme les êtres humains
à une femme et à rien les terriens voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
obama est-ce qu'il est sexy aux vins
les deux ensembles en fait ce sont au
final ils sont adorables et il sera là
c'est que si manu qui ont
foulé la porte je trouve sexy la porte
bien les écrits bien sûr c'est aussi
par le jambon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors enfin son honneur on va voir si
vous savez les reconnaître voulait me
dire rumeurs par humeur ok scandale au
mans apparemment à cause des rtt les 24
heures du mans ne durerait cette année
que 21h humeur par la mer
grâce au tgv elles sont le cas de
troisième guerre mondiale les allemands
ne serait plus qu'à 2 heures 20
par humeur
gilles eddine zidane se serait mis à la
pétanque pour occuper sa retraite et
aurait eu une dérogation pour pouvoir
jouer avec les pieds rumeurs parues
après la défaite 63 9 du quinze de
france contre l'uruguay ex bernard
laporte aurait porté plainte contre les
joueurs néo zélandais pour coups et
blessures
pour le prochain test match contre
l'équipe de france et all blacks serait
prévu d'envoyer leurs épouses
selon une étude très sérieuse les all
blacks serait les quinze seul noir au
monde que personne n'aurait jamais osé
traité de [ __ ]
afin de préparer ses joueurs à affronter
les all blacks ce bernard laporte aurait
prévu de les emmener aux autres
vincennes pour s'entraîner à plaquer des
rhinocéros
noirs mais c'est une bonne idée a pris
de pensées
les sièges médicale de rigueur pour la
coupe du monde de rugby en france
bernard laporte jean louis aurait mis au
point une tactique imparable pour battre
les all blacks ce et qui consistera à
leur donner une mauvaise adresse pour le
stade
c'est confirmé si marianne james pleure
aussi souvent pendant la nouvelle star
c'est qu'elle serait en train de penser
aux ventes de son album
rumeur ou baru la rumeur l a fait avec
beaucoup de courage mais c'est vrai un
peu plein la gueule les courageux déjà
de s'habiller comme
mercredi soir c est vrai qu avec la
couronne de travers
on continue avec notre ami manoukian
malgré ce qu'il dit manu katché n'aurait
jamais été le batteur de peter gabriel
mais celui de peter et sloane
[Rires]
bonheur suite à un contre un
publicitaire de 28 à s'appellerait l'an
prochain palmolive attias
[Applaudissements]
le prochain concert de steeve estatof de
la nouvelle star aurait lieu ligne 4 au
métro odéon tous les jours de 10h à 22h
avec des entretiens l'album de son nez
maintenant que roland garros est
terminée on aura aperçu philippe lavil
perdu dans le bois de boulogne se
demandant ce qu'ils allaient faire
jusqu'à l'an prochain
le film je vous trouve très beau
d'isabelle mergault serait l'objet d'un
remake aux états unis avec bill murray
dans le rôle de michelle blanc oui mr
paris meurs meurs absolue loire magloire
aurait été victime d'une crise cardiaque
sur le plateau de morning café après
avoir réalisé qu'en fait cette émission
passe est vraiment à la télé
c'est quoi il a eu un malaise vagal
à cause de lui j'ai des chihuahuas la
maison
nathalie vincent l'animatrice de
incroyable mais vrai se verrait bien
tourné avec tarantino par humeur et
éventuellement en france avec alain
chabat paru bien donc on croit rumeurs
la ville
philippe lucas l'entraîneur de laure
manaudou aurait développé une nouvelle
technique pour l'entraînement de ses
nageuses en les obligeant remonter les
cours d'eau comme des saumons
en inde la guerre du cachemire aurait
été élu guerre la plus élégante de
l'histoire
à
entrer dans la colle qui faisait chuter
son cholestérol
jacques weber ferait prochainement la
publicité de dans l'alcool le premier
entre la vodka qui fait oublier qu'on
fait des pubs de merde
pour faire les économies dans son
nouveau club guy roux aurait prévu de
faire voyager son équipe en auto-stop
lors des déplacements
wenner
ça c'est drôle si ça y passe les
producteurs de films porno se servirait
des cris des joueuses de tennis durant
les échanges ont doublé leur fils par
l'humeur des rumeurs ouais bravo
[Musique]
m
alors là est brève
le sav des émissions continuent l'année
prochaine
ouais
[Musique]
alors si on veut se plaindre de votre
émission on appelle biais
et ben on n'a plus personne ne dit rien
et puis là on va parler d'un cd de
mokobé qui s'appelle mon afrique alors
c'est un disque qu'elles ont participé
youssou ndour diam's salif keita amadou
et mariam booba et ça vous plaît oui
beaucoup et pourquoi mokobé c'est un
garçon qu'on connaît bien et qui est
beau déjà qu'ils se créent deux garçons
oui c'est vrai non mais sensible aux
charmes des africains
et non et voilà c'est hip hop mais il ya
quand même beaucoup de sonorités
africaines parce qu'on parle de musique
africaine mais c'est très divers dont il
ya de la musique un peu plus ce afrique
de l'ouest genre le sénégal il ya un peu
coupé décalé qui viennent la côte
d'ivoire c'est très très mélangées comme
ça on profite un peu un puis l'album
porte bien son nom parce que c'est mon
afrique et on voyage bien à travers
l'afrique dans cet album et puis il ya
un certain discours que je voulais sera
appréciée quoi voilà mokobé mme en
afrique il faut l'écouter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jacquet stéphane guillon
[Applaudissements]
c'est tendu la main
mais d'abord le zapping de canal voilà
c'était le zapping de canal la revue de
presse maintenant de stéphane guillon
ces femmes c'est qu'on peut pas parler
politique veille d'élections que vous
savez j'en parlais pas d'accord on vous
écoute quand même
élections législatives en belgique
yves leterme remporte 31% des voix sans
droit d'en parler tout le monde s'en
fout mais
alors à ce propos je vous ai fait trois
infos on s'en fout mais on peut en
parler stéphane bern adore le sport
hippique
9 6 sur 10 possèdent un téléphone
portable paris s'il tonne refuse de
déféquer aux toilettes en prison pardon
ça on peut en parler
société clichy interdit les mini motos
ça c'est dégueulasse pour les gens de
petite taille parce que eux c'est leur
moto norman mimie mathy ou d'autres ne
veulent pas en un seul run
soyez
la pêche au thon continue et bling
thomas toujours en danger
une info gala sylvie vartan avec le
temps je deviens plus fragiles c'est
normal si lui c'est l'ostéoporose
sport selon la société philips se raser
c'est comme piloter une formule 1 et ça
c'est quand franck ribéry se rase
du cal
c'est un super rasoir amanda lear la
commande et demain pour la fête des
pères
télévisions à paris emmanuel chat
organise le premier salon du petit écran
plusieurs stands le jean luc delarue
le sébastien cauet
le michel drucker
le thierry ardisson
est enfin très attendu le stand
jardinage pascal sevran
ont quand même ce salon avec une
nouveauté qui devrait intéresser andré
manoukian une nouvelle star à l'envers
on vote pour que des chanteurs connus
redevienne anonyme
et
ça donnerait sa oui tu t'appelles
comment mathieu mireille vas-y on
t'écoute stop manu katché tu en penses
quoi écoute mireille si j'ai envie
d'écouter piaf je me fais pas chier je
vais acheter l'album à la fnac
physiquement tu es coiffé comme un
playmobil en plus c'est la chanteuse
préférée de stéphane bern ça fait trois
raisons tu dégages
régine marianne un commentaire pardon je
suis je suis très émue j'ai déjà des
petites larmes est venue chanter dans
l'état où tu es une chanson de madonna
en plus manu a eu très peur que comme
elle tu balances ta culotte au public tu
l'as pas fait merci fait juste gaffe
quand tu bouges au fil de ta paire ça me
rappelle un représentant
carla bruni alesi marianne tu en penses
quoi j'ai j'ai rien entendu d'autre part
et manu est là elle a chanté andrey
moi je trouve que tu as une voix sublime
sublime sublime sublime le fait que tu
fasses 85 60 86 ça donne à voir un grain
extraordinaire je vais te laisser mon
portable qu'on en parle tranquillement
ce soir à la maison par contre quand tu
arrives tape sur l'interphone avec le
poids sinon je n'entendrai pas
merci à la semaine prochaine voici le
classement
si ces vins
et voilà devant le public de plus ce
soir le jeu du point commun quel est le
point commun entre
marie drucker
vanessa paradis
nathalie marquay
eva longoria et la société générale
on se retrouve à la rue
je suis
le thème
et
[Musique]
très bon choix
l'émission qui se suit avec lui
et voilà
d'abord d'abord le résultat du jeu de
plus quel est le point commun entre
marie drucker vanessa paradis nathalie
marquay eva longoria et la société
générale un homme n'a une femme n'a un
objet non excusées échappe ou non elles
ont tourné avec un real qui a fait non
alors je vais vous donner un indice omar
pourrait en faire partie ils vont se
marier voilà ils vont se marier et la
société générale va épouser la belle
était
alors le sujet de la semaine c'est
évidemment les élections législatives
mais comme on n'a pas le droit d'en
parler on a cherché autre chose on a
trouvé le nouveau marketing musique avec
les erreurs pour toi mais bon c'est
comme ça en regardant en vain
ça veut dire m brasse les 303 la mise
vous voulez toucher le jackpot alors agi
j'ai pensé à devenir producteur de
disques c'est facile faites le calcul un
fait les vierges 5 centimes d'euro et le
même produit avec une pochette vaut 15
euros dans les bacs 300 fois plus cher
les mêmes marges que dans le pratique de
drogue sauf que c'est légal de vendre
des disques à ce prix alors bien sûr il
va vous falloir un chasseur léger dames
bonjour petites gens sont tout de même
un but c'est que jamais
vient du blues les chanteurs on leur
jette trois pièces dans les tuyaux
guitare il voit boire un coup et bob
pouces qu'on leur raconte d'ailleurs
s'il vous réclame une augmentation
vous n'aurez pas écrire son nom en plus
gros sur la pochette et c'est lui qui
vous dira merci mais voilà c'est pas
tout gagner beaucoup d'argent ce que
vous voulez c'est gagner beaucoup
d'argent tout de suite alors là pour le
chat potté que prescillia de méthode
elle dit à l'ancienne pour ça n'importe
quel demi volée toral à faire même s'ils
chantent mal
un peu plus fort boyard vu qu'il est
connu il sera invité à la télé pour
faire sa promo quand on pense aux
millions de dépenses et marchands de
lessive pour faire leur pub vous voyez
un peu l'économie le problème c'est que
les gens déjà connus ont souvent un
avocat qui relie leur contrat et là ça
peut faire plonger la courbe de beni
doula deuxième méthode big nouvelles
méthodes ont choisi des gens qui
chantent mal mais cette fois totalement
inconnu et qui n'ont pas d'avocat
on leur fait signer un contrat qui leur
donne droit pendant cinq ans et l'un
seulement une fois qu'ils vont renoncer
à tous on était passé dans une émission
de télé réalité diffusée pendant témoin
à des millions de gens vous en faites
pas ça ne se verra pas donc fait ça que
pour l'argent vous n'aurez qu'à dire que
vous voulez aider les jeunes artistes
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que tous les
producteurs ne sont pas ça pour l'argent
il reste encore dans ce métier quelques
sentimentaux qui se foutent du fric et
qui ne font ce métier que pour coucher
avec des chanteuses
[Applaudissements]
six mois
pour lever le ton coup chaque de santé
puisque je parle mais je par contre
c'est vrai que je tombe je tombe
amoureux et j'ai besoin de ça pour
fonctionner ouais mais la grosse
différence après c'est que quand tu as
couché du coup la voix elle te fait plus
le même effet donc du coup tu as a prêté
un peu plus mais c'est vrai quand tu l'a
connu au sens biblique du terme il ya un
point de séduction après tu vas plus que
les mauvais côté c'est pour ça qu'il ya
de mal argué au bout de sept ans a
démarré elle pourrait des tacles sans
arrêt lui couche pas avec ses joueurs il
arrive à leur faire des compliments tu
vois ce que je veux dire la voie royale
maintenant pour devenir chanteur c'est
quoi la météo sur m6 c'est le problème
c'est aux accès aux médias quoi moi je
me rappelle il ya 15 ans quand on a
commencé il y avait plein d'émissions de
télé le moins deux chanteurs qui
arrivait il faisait danièle gilbert à
midi tout le monde a commencé là a bien
évolué la feb 1885 mais voilà [ __ ]
c'était sa première télé quand on était
impressionnée elle avait peur qu'il
attaque et tout est beau la chanson en
même temps au fur et à mesure ses
chansons sur la sodomie
[Rires]
andré manoukian il n'y a pas que la
nouvelle star dans votre vie 1 il ya
aussi paris première ou fait une
émission qui s'appelle des doigts de fée
1 vous êtes invités cet été dans la
boîte à musique sur france 2 vous
continuez à écrire des chansons i avec
ses ventes albums de malia et l'album
s'appelle young boys voilà
wall a vu tanzanie
[Musique]
open
non en masse
[Musique]
soit admis aux soins
l'album s'appelle une bonne leçon à la
cigale les 12 septembre
[Applaudissements]
à l'image de canon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces balades à new york et est là elle a
entendu un indice de lianes qui
tournaient dans un magasin elle aimait
bien le soin d'aller faire du ski ski en
anglais elle dit elle a cru que j'étais
quincy jones et de manque de bol est
tombé sur moi et voilà à l'habiter
landry on s'est rencontrés c'était juste
génial quoi c'est très bien
[Applaudissements]
vous avez mal y est la nouvelle star de
vos phrases cultes à faire un quiz
d'aidé a dit
ça sent trop le savons et pas assez la
foufoune si vous comprenez l'image
d'aidé a dit il bien pu dire tdi dit ça
si on chantait avec le cul vous seriez
soprano à garnier
j'aime bien le côté d'un amoussou
riposte modern vintage vous chantez
comme personne enfin personne d'humains
bien sûr des
dvd peut dire ça pour brancher d'aidé
mais l'apathie
mademoiselle je n'oublie jamais un
visage mais pour vous je vais faire une
exception 2d à 10
[Rires]
ces gauchos maps qui l'a dit c'est dans
des moments comme ça qu'on a envie de se
suicider
ne vient pas de là vous chantez comme
dans un bar à [ __ ] de gauche
j'ai un faible pour les chanteuses avec
des grosses couilles alors je vais vous
dire oui de 2,10 du détective vous savez
que je peux vous faire gagner mais je
voudrais très gentille dédié
on a fait chanter des tortues des
grenouilles bientôt des spermatozoïdes
mais vous on veut plus vous entendre
chanter et diaby
yann fetwa opérette hume a encore crevé
l'oeil avec ton nez ddm
[Applaudissements]
maintenant mes enfants passent au
champion de l'actu alors ils veulent
plus et plus des quiz à la con là on
compte les points oui on n'est pas là
pour rigoler attention à la fin il y
aura un champion ou une championne de
l'actuelle tout est possible on se
concentre car
comment george bush at il appelé le pape
benoît 16 lors de leur entrevue qu'a
majesté
ben
votre sainteté jean paul 16 mon cher
pape ou monsieur
monsieur monsieur frère
aujourd'hui ils sont
1532 ce sont les ex de nathalie
marquay-pernaut
les spectateurs des dalton d'eric et
ramzy les candidats au bac cette année
où les hommes qui ont un micro pénis en
france notre candidat au bac clara
morgane
elle ses capacités en gros pénis car
dans les enfants de la télé ramzy de
eric et ramzy a perdu les pédales une
bonne occasion de se taire sa
crédibilité un billet de 100 euros une
donc ses chances une dans le raid
quels objets ayant appartenu à john
lennon est en vente à new york pour 280
mille euros un lit dans lequel il a fait
l'amour pour la dernière fois à yoko ono
un sextoy sa dernière paire de lunettes
le piano sur lequel il a joué quelques
heures avant sa mort où sa pipe à crack
et ligne le pilote piano manoukian
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine un jeune épileptique a
fait une crise et s'est évanoui avant
d'être hospitalisé pour quoi ils jouent
aux jeux vidéo il regardait fixement une
boule à facettes disent qu ils
regardaient céline l'émission spéciale
céline dion au téléphone il regardait le
logo des jeux olympiques 2012 à londres
il essayait de regarder le porno de
canal en crypté le logo de langue fred
barreaux et une grosse mer
[Applaudissements]
goûter qui a coûté 1 million d'euros les
anglais ils sont fous furieux de quelle
manière pamela anderson vient-elle de
réaliser le rêve de sa vie en faisant
une orgie en se faisant peser un
troisième ça en rachetant la maison en
forme et marilyn monroe en devenant
l'assistante sur scène magicien de las
vegas ou en devenant réaliser un
magicien 10 assists en plus
raide
largement en tête suivi par clara
morgane
qu'est ce que le bowling à nice mme
phénomène récemment apparue en france un
terme désignant la tendance à l'obésité
chez les enfants un terme désignant la
montée de la violence dans le milieu de
la pétanque un terme désignant le fait
d'être mariée à un homme surnommé bulli
en désignant un sport consistant à
descendre des collines roulé en boule
les collines les collines pour toi
comment ça fait un bout sur la hulotte
moi aussi à lutter sur la lune la bouffe
non c'est un terme désignant la montée
de la violence dans le milieu de la
pétanque les boules idée
[Musique]
je ne connais pas mâcher un bowling un
afficheur boule guère comment s'appelle
nouveau one woman show de charlotte de
turckheim mon pèse personne me fais la
gueule oh la vache tendu comme un string
ç'aurait pu être pire où ça va nettement
mieux
on voit qu'à pas de mec en ce moment à
quel temps d'hier le journal as
j'entends parler mais c'est bien c'est
bien qu'elle vienne émission va revenir
à l'antenne en septembre prochain la
nuit des héros perdus de vue sacrée
soirée lunettes noires pour nuit blanche
le club dorothée sacrée soirée sacrée
soirée fred et la porte
[Applaudissements]
bon ba na na na na
qui choisissent un numéro il appelait
endurance lors
qu'est ce que tu penses qu est ce que je
la stéphane le duo gagnant donc
maintenant entre fred et clara n'y a que
vous qui pouvez jouer et c'est l'abbé
attention à qui sont ses seins
à la co présentatrice des enfants de la
télé à la présentatrice de la nouvelle
star halak ou présentatrice de la
méthode cauet ou à la co présentatrice
de la roue de la fortune
ou à la présentatrice du journal du hard
la présentatrice de la roue de la
fortune non frais ça me rappelle clara
moi non regarde ils ont fait six morts
bah oui mais non
divulguée ce sont les salles de virginie
efira et oui on se régale
s'intitulera le prochain livre de
stéphane bern la france envers la reine
des connes plus belle sera la vie beau
comme un dieu ou l'homme qui voulait
être reine l'homme qui voulait non plus
le seul avis carnot
et donc
quelle est la carte postale la plus
vendue au monde la tour eiffel la statue
de la liberté une plage de hawaï avec un
coucher de soleil une paire de fesses
avec écrit alors
mr ces femmes qui a gagné je pense que
c'est clara morgane regrets la
championne de l'actus cette semaine et
[Applaudissements]
bravo on
est là on devrait bonne option
[Applaudissements]
sortir le fusil
tél
là
photo temps tous les u15 de france
jour j
andré manoukian
pour yukon
on arriverait pour rendre
bon je vous laisse aller
rendez vous
sérieux
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu